This is going to be day three of
world models work.
So, yesterday we got it to kind of sort
of do something a small fraction of the
time. Better than nothing.
Today I'm going to see how much of this
stuff we can just bolt on and make it
work.
It's difficult because I'm like I'm
strongly biased against a lot of the
stuff in this paper just because of all
the ablations I've done and I know like
certain bits of it don't actually
transfer.
But we'll start with this anyways and
we'll see how far we get.
So, I think first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to actually add in
uh the decoder. There.
too much. Right.
We'll give it
hidden size yellow
Do we do like
next OBS?
D loss and then let's just do
uh recon loss.
Take all next OBS
and then what? MB ops.
any opinions on Ark?
Sorry. Um, is that the Ark challenge or
something else?
How the heck did this stop?
Yes.
Uh well, it's not similar to RL in some
sense because it's not learnable from
the problem itself. It's like human
intuition as a hard requirement.
Like the interaction in those problems
is very trivial. It's basically just
like
Yeah, like the interaction in those
problems is very trivial. It's a lot
more just pattern recognition with very
light interactive elements added.
did something like change in in this
somehow I don't understand
Okay, this is getting
this is getting weird. Like, what the
hell's happening?
Oh, I see. I named
I think I named uh I named it the same
thing.
I just named two things the same thing
by mistake.
Okay. Well, it doesn't immediately make
it work.
Now let's see
let's see to what extent I'm matching
the uh the network here
yeah I can move this so that the
sequence model takes
yeah sequence model has to change.
So
D takes in
H and observations
sequence model takes action.
Okay.
So all I need to do for this is action
embedding
amx becomes hidden size.
this also takes an action,
right?
Yes.
Okay. So now we have
and then the encoder needs to also take
hidden
Okay. So here
we need to get Z
O device date
like so. Right.
Then this is going to be logits and
value.
Going to take Z
also take
hopefully something like this works.
Yeah.
Oh, because I didn't modify it, of
course.
Right.
If I get this to actually be like
reasonably directionally correct,
then I can I mean I can make all this
very simple. That's the easy part for me
at least.
Well, not easy necessarily, but that's
one of the things I'm quite good
Why?
Wait, what?
Yep.
Dummy.
what the hell's wrong with this?
There we go.
The default dynamics is missing action.
Dynamics no longer needs action.
In fact,
we can do with dynamics
This is kind of going to just be day
three of pretty heavy on uh research
stuff.
It's not always the most interesting
thing because it's, you know, I have to
get pretty deep into the implementation
into the papers. Um, but this is how the
sausage is made ultimately.
I mean the only other alternative
basically to this would be me starting
from uh like the released code and then
trying to convert that first into like a
readable PyTorch for formula and then
into Puffer but I just I know the state
of how bad that repository is and yeah
that would be rough.
real time 3D world model. Very curious
about sim real in that case.
Um,
so I can see why you would think that
those things go together.
I don't necessarily think that those
things go together as cleanly as you
think, though. I think it's more the
case that the way that I look at what
I'm doing here, ignore the thing that
like the world model is like this. Like
ignore everything that comes to mind
when you hear world model and just think
of it this way. Right now with Puffer,
if you have a ton of data, Puffer is
ludicrously fast. Like you can train
models on hard problems on your laptop.
What we don't have is a way to crank
down the amount of uh the amount of data
that you have available. crank up the
amount of compute and still have it
work.
We've kind of covered one side of RL. We
haven't gone to the other side. And what
I'm trying to do, ignore the fact that
it's a world model or off policy or
search or any ignore the specifics of
the method. The goal here is ultimately
just to have a knob that we can turn
between compute and data. That's it.
All problems will lie on that manifold.
10k training steps per second. You get
what?
10k training steps. We get millions of
training steps per second. What are you
talking about?
How do you get so many millions or
number of msteps? mst steps and training
gradients because every sample on
average every sample is used once. So
millions of steps per second includes
the environment simulation, the forward
pass for inference, the forwards pass
for training time and the backwards pass
plus you know applying the optimizer.
All of that is millions of steps per
second.
Well, I mean, there's a whole bunch of
material around this and also the code
is fairly simple. Um, the short answer
to this though without just put linking
you to my blogs is ridiculously fast
simulations. We have like 50,000 lines
worth of C for our own simulators at
this point. We have a lot of infra that
makes uh us able to maintain that speed
all the way up to when the data is ready
to be used for training. We have
optimized large batch optimized large
batch trainer with some additional
tricks there. And then uh finally like
literally just nobody bothered to
optimize this stuff properly before. And
if you do the back of the napkin math
like puffer could be even faster than it
is now. We're not even close to using
the uh the full potential of a of what a
GPU can E
playing around with puffer
and is it the LSTM That's the secret
source. Here is Mamba and is 20x lower
than a normal run.
Mamba was 20x lower. Well, I don't know
how well you optimize that, right?
Heart pull might see better results.
20x slower.
Um,
when you say 20x slower, it takes 20x
more samples or the training was 20x
slower.
you familiar with Band or Victor
Tailins? If that's the guy with the
avatar profile, then yeah,
I have no idea if what that guy is doing
makes any sense or whatever, but it's
cool and it's outside of the norm and we
need more people doing stuff that fits
that description. So, power to him.
At the least the sense I've gotten is
whatever he's doing, he honestly
believes that it will work and make
sense. Um,
so yeah, I hope it I hope it This
uh if you were to explain what's going
on here to someone with no background
knowledge, how would you do so? Asking
for myself. Okay, so let me take a crack
at that. What you're watching here is
reinforcement learning research uh being
done in real time to advance science. I
develop uh a very high performance
toolkit for reinforcement learning and I
use it to do a bunch of core research.
Reinforcement learning is a subbranch of
AI that deals with learning purely from
interaction with an environment. Either
be a simulator, a game, a robot, the
real world, what have you. Uh this was a
very obscure area where it was very
difficult to do research in just a year
ago. I've made it substantially more
accessible. We now have hundreds of
people all getting involved with this
field and doing stuff around our tools.
And at the same time as we've made it
easier to get into, we're also pushing
forward the state-of-the-art through
just very very efficient computation,
enabling us to run experiments thousands
of times faster than would have been
possible before.
That's my best crack at it.
I have a whole bunch of slightly longer
articles than that if you want more
explanation or are looking to get into
this stuff.
Thanks for your answer. I want to train
more RL models to get better intuition.
Yeah. Wait, let me just make sure. You
were the one who asked about world
models, right?
Yeah. So um what I would say is like
if you just read my like intro
programming ML article it you just need
to have a huge amount of skepticism for
science in general and for like clever
ideas. Um, you know, when you hear world
model, like you naturally associate it
with other things that like, oh, well,
this looks like this other thing I'm
familiar with, but oftentimes you're
kind of just like slapping
like slapping fancy words on different
pretty opaque methods and like the
highle connections you might make, like
they're almost always wrong if they're
not very very deeply grounded in how the
methods actually work.
batch processing full but running 3 to
4K
front end back end to Mamba.
So 3 to 4K is definitely off. Uh you'd
need to say like how big the network is
and stuff FBR or like if you have a a
comparably sized network, you should be
able to pretty much get anything over a
million steps a second. Hey Captain,
been busy. Not sure what's happening
post 3 other than the fact you presented
Puffer at a conference. Congrats. Thank
you. Yeah, Puffer got a I was somewhat
surprised. Um, Puffer got a the only
award I've really ever gotten in any of
my work is like the screw you paper
that's written in a way that's like not
at all the norm. But hey, I'm happy
about that. At least it'll get more
people into the space for sure. Uh, so
what I've been doing, Captain, I've been
sort of splitting my time through a
bunch of different uh over a bunch of
different things. Right now, I'm doing
uh a few weeks of just like follow-up
research, testing out ideas and stuff
from the conference, trying to see if we
can get core uh core breakthroughs to
power Puffer 4. I'm also working on
various different applications that are
like industry adjacent looking for
professional opportunities for puffer as
well as know directly talking to new
companies and uh doing work for existing
clients. So I'm splitting my time among
a bunch of different things. Um but yeah
that's generally the gist of it.
Making code that allows the AI to teach
itself through experience pretty much.
Yeah, that's the lay version of it.
long overdue.
I mean, it's a nice
it's a nice extra at the very least.
Frankly though, the thing that I'm
mostly focused on now is like
I this there's like one really big
remaining problem with puffer, right, is
that we're really restricted to high
data regime. I'd like to have a clean
method that lets us sort of dial between
high data and low data. And if we can do
that with like some sort of comparable
performance to the rest of what is out
there in that space at the least then
like then I can really just optimize the
hell out of this thing and we'll have
the field in a good spot.
Introductory papers. Oh yeah. So for
people watching um here if you want
material on this stuff generally
I write a bunch of long form content
here on X base 5341.
If you just click my articles tab you
can see there are a whole bunch of
opinion pieces. There's a whole bunch of
technical pieces and then there are
these two guides that you know people
have found quite helpful. Uh this is for
general programming and ML. This is
really good advice for uh how to do good
engineering and how to get in science
get get into scientific research. And
then this is RL specific.
And this takes you through in a way
that's quite accessible.
Low data training is so you can train on
something like robots real time and not
well just generally so that you can
apply this to a broader range of
problems right captain Then
Okay. So, this is the new
uh the new version of this. This is
closer to RSSM.
Now, I need to make sure that this is
not broken.
posted screenshot of it learning
breakout.
You'd have to link me more details. Um,
you'd have to link me more details about
this. Let me see.
Yeah, there's no way that you have a
31,000 parameter model that's training
at 2,000 steps per second.
You've like reduced number of M's and
stuff a bunch.
Yeah, you're doing optimizations that
you definitely don't even need to start
looking at. Like you don't need Bloat
16. What? Like you should just be able
to get a million.
Why switch back to I didn't captain.
This is a different desktop that already
had an install setup that I didn't want
to bother to mess with. This is not WSL
right now. This is me being sshed into a
native Linux box just happening to be
from Windows.
Honestly, I probably should have just
like reinstalled this box when I got
here because then I wouldn't have been
able to download League.
It's all right. I'm bad enough at that
game that it's like not fun for that for
like too long of periods of time.
I did finally get out of iron. Most
impressive.
What happens when you do research all
day
while you're implementing is
recent one that plays 100 video games by
itself? Uh it's sort of dreamer v3ish.
The thing is that there's like a whole
bunch of adjacent stuff around that
paper that we've done that like a lot of
that parts of that paper don't work the
way that they're written. So
we're doing world model stuff in general
both of them and I I would just go take
your model and like take your model like
make up some batches of data and see how
fast it runs because there's something
very wrong there. It shouldn't be that
slow. Do you define the agent goals or
do you create enable? Uh it's trained
through so reinforcement learning is
trained through rewards a reward signal.
So it's like some very basic highle
thing like agent gets a reward if it
scores a point or if it like gets to an
objective or whatever. But you don't
tell it how to actually do that. It has
to figure it all out. So it's basically
the equivalent of training something by
initially mashing random buttons, seeing
what happens, and then getting better
over time.
It's like a very powerful It's a very
powerful toolkit and one that's not
really uh paid enough attention to I
think at the moment in uh in research.
Well, this runs
This is kind of screwy. I actually don't
know if it's the previous action or the
why I hate these models. Like this model
just doesn't make ton of good sense.
supposed to take the previous action,
the previous state Z.
So wait the the recurrent portion
actually doesn't get to see
doesn't get to see the previous OB. uh
doesn't get to see
observation at all.
Yeah. So, the recurrent portion actually
doesn't get to see this stuff at all.
Okay. This is like a really really wonky
I'm going to try to actually match this
stuff today.
And we just do like this.
Prev Z.
So
this has to be
chat. Does anyone know where to start
reading about hierarchical models?
You're assuming that there are
hierarchical models that work. That is
like not actually
I mean that's like a 50/50 that there
are any that work, man.
Check
the capture the flag paper for one of
the simpler formulations that like might
actually work.
I'm trying to replicate this as closely
as I can, but this is just like a stupid
model.
This is like the most Byzantine
unnecessarily confused thing imaginable.
Hey, that guy was just like he's doing
things like
it's like net equal like net like B
equals subnet of A, right? And then
he'll like concat A and B together and
like give them to another thing. So he's
basically like they're implicit skip
connections everywhere. But like
and like if I knew that the paper was
good quality science and like these
things were actually well motivated I
was like oh okay sure I can just
implement all this but the thing is I
know that the I know the quality of the
science in this paper's crap right but I
know that none of these these things
were actually tested.
So like there, you know, a million
pieces of complexity
and like you don't even know which ones
you have to implement in order for the
thing to work.
This is why I'm doing this in such short
hours. Frankly, I'm doing like six,
five, six uh was it five to seven hours
of this a dayish.
And to be fair, I can't exactly say the
rest of the day is
well,
it's uh not exactly relaxing, but it is
good for mental
what you deriving the math would look
like.
Well, I mean, this isn't math. Like,
this is this is architecture made to
look like math, right? Is what this
thing is.
Like there literally isn't any math
that's actually justified.
It's like a whole bunch of empirical
modeling that's made to look like formal
math.
I can do architecture work and empirical
work, right?
It's actually very difficult to recall
to mind like anything that like anything
remotely recent and useful where like
the thing was actually motivated by the
mathematical definition and doesn't work
without the theoretical side
rebuilding the architecture using the
same baseline concept. Well, that's kind
of what I'm doing. The problem is,
right, the problem is you have no idea
at what point it's supposed to start
working.
Like I got it to last night where with
like a very simplified world model
version I could get it to do better than
random like substantially better than
random on cart pole like one in 10
times.
These days, we're going to have all the
RL solved. We're back to optimizing
everything nicely. Make RL really
simple. We're going to have all these
good environments. field's just going to
be solved. How it's going to be
till then I fight with existing papers
and poor quality science and shitty
implementation code
until eventually all be fixed.
how I view it
be a complete embarrassment that the
actual field is of like this low quality
stuff as a whole.
This is the
state
action. Okay. So then action equals
head
access variable Z.
Where the hell am I here
in state? Right? Because we need
previous Z, right?
[Music]
Decode action.
Oh, yes.
You literally don't return this at all.
You just return hidden.
Drone Mus is continuous. Do you know if
anything special is needed?
Train. Uh, no. It seems like to vary
environment by environment, captain.
We've had like several continuous
environments where it just works fine.
We've had several that seem like
piddley.
As you can see though, there has been
there has been progress around here.
Okay, good. We actually got up to this
spot.
Let me see if I can figure out
for eval on Z and state.
Then you do the dynamics
need actions in this thing.
You don't need logits or actions, right?
Just need
you just need Z,
right? And then rewards and terminals.
What do these take? These take both as
well. Damn it. Yes, they do.
Okay, we'll just have to change those.
Find me a girl with RL in your next
project.
Uh, I that depends. Do you consider
working out reinforcement learning?
Go reinforcement learn yourself a little
bit.
How much would you say the hardware
limits progress in your work in
research?
Do I have the picture somewhere?
Where's the Oh, yeah. Here. Here's the
hardware.
We have uh 20
20 4090s
for use in the project. And uh you know,
we let a lot of our contributors use
these as well. And it turns out that
when you make everything a thousand
times faster than it used to be and you
have a handful of GPUs, you're pretty
well set up. But I think mostly
it's mostly skill limitations at this
point, like being able to quickly and
effectively
run all sorts of different experiments,
source things from different pieces of
literature, uh, you know, have more
environments being merged in, optimize
on engineering side. It's mostly just
like
needing more people involved and more
people gaining the skills to work on the
harder bits.
Kind of one of the cool things though is
that this type of research compared to a
lot of the other stuff out there is
really not that hardware limited.
Why not one H200?
Because one H200 will be about the speed
of one of those 4090s. And then you've
spent 20 grand on a card that's just
like a big freaking paper weight.
Like those cards are not magically super
fast. They're just magically super
expensive
at least for small models.
20 parallel M's on it, can't you? That
doesn't matter. We literally we load
like thousands of parallel environments
on uh our 4090s already. That's not the
bottleneck.
That's only the bottleneck for like LM
people with the stupidly large models
and then people who have stupidly
unoptimized Sims.
What's your goal with world models? Just
fun to get decentation.
No, the goal is directly to have a knob
in Puffer Lab that we can have more
compute efficiency or more data
efficiency. Right now, Puffer is
incredibly compute efficient, but not
data efficient, right? Okay. So, you
have to have fast Sims for Puffer to
really be able to work at full
potential, but we're working on that
trade-off.
What would you say a wife will limit
progress?
A good one should do the opposite,
right?
trade-offs coming from simulated ends.
Um, the trade-offs are coming from
different problems. Uh, having access to
different speed simulators. So, a lot of
my work has just been, hey, you probably
just built your simulator dumb. Let's
just make your simulator fast and then
throw a really fast RL on that and then
you just win. And that actually works
for a surprisingly large number of
problems. enough that like there's
already a ton of stuff we can do in
industry with puffer as it is right now.
But, you know, if you want to just have
everything be in scope, then you also do
this type of stuff.
RL and dating advice. I look, I'm not
the person you should ask. Uh, because I
kind of just like do my thing and work
out and do research and not all that
much else. But if you're asking me
questions that aren't absolutely insane,
I'm going to reply.
Just know that I might be trolling you
half the time.
What?
I don't know the detailed personal lives
of either of those.
I mean, the answer to any question of
that form, though, is I'd rather be me.
There a Z loss and a reconstruction
loss. Are there two separate losses or
am I dumb?
Yeah. Okay. I'm just dumb. There is not
there are not two separate losses. Just
a reconstruction law.
What we just do is we just do we just do
all Z, right?
Then you append Z.
And then we do going to need to recon.
All right. So, next ops.
You don't even need to store a Z for
this.
You just take your Z loss here or your
recon loss going to be all next OBS.
Need all Z. Don't need all Z prreds.
Four terminals. This is actually
simpler, but unfortunately I do have to
do this gross thing where reward
terminal and recon Come on.
Okay. So, here
we got through this chunk.
We get through this chunk. Right now, we
need to do this thing again.
At least the way I've set it up, we do.
We need to do this thing again.
And this Z is also wrong.
This is not the previous action either,
is it?
Previous action. I did it right up top
up here.
What the hell? Where's previous action
in this?
[Music]
effective limiting overall number of
interactions.
Huh? Did it work?
You done any research into using super
fast Sims as world models
as the world? That doesn't make sense
fundamentally.
Like that's called just not doing a
world model, right? That's like what
Puffer is by default.
Yeah, now you're getting way outside of
the area of research that I've uh I've
worked in. I can't really comment
intelligently on that.
Okay. So, we can run this.
Now, of course, the question is going to
be because literally we had this working
like one and 10 times before.
Um, did I break it or not?
like above 25 or above like 27 is better
than uh default for reference.
Very unstable though.
What game do you think would be a really
cool end for RL to solve? I mean one
that you can practically solve or like
longer term because obviously my thesis
is neural MMO and I'm always going to
come back to MMOs.
it a few times and then we'll start
checking.
Well, yeah. Then MMOs like I don't know,
pick one. Runescape, World of Warcraft,
whatever.
was not exactly
the motivation's completely different
here, right? It's not just like
scripting random stupid things. It's if
you get RL working on an MMO from
scratch, you basically have general
intelligence.
Let me see if I've done this actually
remotely correctly. So
take the previous Z
you eval
the in state
compute Z and you do actor and value off
of Z right
that we do eval
is that what I
Yes. So it's you do 40 eval dynamics.
Okay.
40 eval
dynamics.
And then it's uh reward terminal
reconstruct zh.
This should be a Z and H, right?
H.
Ah, the state doesn't get updated,
right?
that has to go there
to have any chance of working.
Then what about actions here?
It's trying. It's not stable.
But that was better than you can get by
random chance.
Oh yeah.
Cool.
Now
uh we start looking to other portions of
this.
I have no idea why that actually works
for reference.
Um, it's possible that I like,
well, to be fair, it's not entirely
surprising. Like the details,
the method is so complex that like a lot
of the details in the reasoning are
going to be pretty obscured.
All right, so
next thing, where's that paper go?
How are these literally all sample
based?
Oh, wait. So, the dynamics predictor.
Hang on. Did I do this right?
Encoder
coder is different.
Oh, what? You're not even using the obs,
are you? Uh oh. Right.
We got to fix that.
Yeah. Okay. I have to fix this
architecture more than before I actually
does a question and call into question a
couple results.
Okay, you don't need dynamics here. So,
this is going to be policy
coder
and this takes
hx
Yeah, we need to really
careful with this. I think
We have
the heck is this?
And for this you don't use
uh the encoder
the dynamics predictor. Right?
Then we do H.
This
All rewards terminals.
That's cool
then.
What do we do?
And
we do.
lucinate trajectories. No, no, no, no.
We're not doing
this. Is for training the dynamics.
Ah, okay.
You do not need dynamics in the world
model.
Oh, wait. You do need dynamics. God damn
it.
Oh, why is this thing so unbelievably
complicated?
I swear it's like you spend a lot of
time in a research building just barely
not too stupid enough to get stuff to
work.
date previous, right? And then Z, which
is the current X.
This is all correct. Okay. And then what
do they do? How do we do the losses on
this?
So there's a representation loss, a
dynamics loss. So there actually there
are five losses here. So there's reward,
continue and reconstruction
and these both operate on X
predict XT
Okay. So this is not next.
This is not next date prediction. This
is a strict
R. So this is just ne this is just you
take Z
and H
do decoding step. Um
then you do your ford eval
t hat or is it the encode? It's the the
encoder, right? The encoder to the
decoder.
So Z is not the dynamic. So we take Z
equals
encode
and this is going to be H and X right
X equals mobs right
like this.
Okay, so we do this
and now we encode
H and X
the dynamics on age
and reward and terminal.
Okay. And then the reconstruction lost
is actually
And this is a reconstruction loss. So
this is just straight up
try to predict this thing. Yes,
several different losses here. So
ward terminal
But it's the same loss otherwise, right?
It's just
P and Q.
Yeah. So this is then just the loss
between.
Oh, so these just are trained to being
like just predict the same thing, right?
So then this is
rep loss.
Okay.
An a prev.
Yeah. So, we'll try something like this.
Okay, we're going to have to keep
checking this thing.
We're getting closer to the actual
formulas, though.
Oh, come on.
Terminal freezing up.
Internet blip at um
server spot, apparently.
That's real bad.
This is such a screwy.
What is this from? This is like the code
book thing, right? From um
is this diffusion models? Like where's
this idea come from?
Let me go check. I have a console that
tells me when internet's down at the
place.
Okay. I guess it was just an internet
blip.
None of the machines actually went down.
audits value from
encoder
see and agency.
Okay.
And then action and log prop from logits
action previous action gets updated
as rev gets updated as well.
Is the consistency better? Not yet.
just like ton of complicated work to do.
But this to me I think that the data
collection phase at least like this this
is now reasonable.
I don't see anywhere where this would be
bad.
Okay. Okay. And then if we go to
training,
go to training,
then it gets more complicated, right? So
we have
X,
we've got a prev,
we've got Z.
You do forward evaluation.
First step here is meaningless.
And then you do encode
on H and X.
You have Z hat.
Then you have your reward predictions
terminal.
Okay.
then and the dynamics gets trained
because you're minimizing
the this encoding.
Okay. And then you have a terminal loss,
representation loss,
obviously production loss,
and you have your reward loss as well,
right?
And then to actually create
trajectories,
we do we roll out
from Zprev
Do Z here.
Z.
This is now Z. And then you do dynamics
for next Z.
You get
terminal
reconstruction.
You don't need to reconstruct actually.
for this phase
and then
this. What the hell am I doing?
Well, no wonder this doesn't work. It
makes no bloody sense. Reward terminal.
I don't think you should need the
sampling
representation for cartpole. Like you
should be able to solve cartpole before
you even get into sampling, right?
This is fine. Right. HZ fix agency.
Agent X.
Fine.
Go to training.
training we do.
Okay. Rev is going to be because the
first action comes before
first obs, right?
where the first ops comes before the
first action rather, right?
Encode on H
the real X. Yeah. And then you do
dynamics here, which takes in
no obs, right? And then you're going to
of course you're going to use the
accurate the not zhat for reward
terminal and
decode. Yes.
Okay. Reward terminal X hat. Yep. This
is all fine.
Your rewards here.
Look at these. But I think fine.
Yeah. This terminal. Okay. That's cool.
Then when we roll out
our imagined trajectories,
uh, we first pause to ban this stupid
bot
away
and then
Wait, this doesn't even get the first
ops. The way that this is written, this
is wrong.
Um,
yeah, this should get the first OBS,
right?
actually. You know, a lot of this stuff
doesn't make much sense now, does it?
I think this is still just like subtly
wrong. to the restroom real quick and
then I'm going to uh
we'll continue we'll continue on this
until I get this Okay.
They also put an alarm so I don't miss
um
scheduled a 4:30 meeting.
Let's actually
let's think a little bit about this.
One sizefits all.
Uh I mean you're going to you should be
able to parameterize
something that works on everything.
It's not going to be like
Basically, I think that the
configuration of your method is going to
contain both the high data regime, low
compute and the high compute, low data
um at the same time. That's the hope.
Now,
we'll see how that works with the world
model stuff specifically.
I might have to make some substantial
changes. We'll see.
But at the very least, like
there is a form of the world model stuff
that should be non-destructive
uh and make it compatible with like the
way that we have stuff on Puffer. Now,
we will simply have to see though.
It's not really about memory at all.
That's like one very small component.
It would make sense to do it the other
way, wouldn't it?
Okay. So, we're going to try
try some stuff, right?
Comment some crap.
We will simply do
okay and then we'll simply do
the
We use this.
Now this one uh this has to work unless
there's a major issue
prob.
Yes.
Okay. So, major major issue then if this
is not working
is to be expected when you have a a
method that's written this.
There you go. Okay. So, it does actually
work when you give it
real data.
At least reasonably, it works somewhat,
right?
Not saying it's great, but does
something.
not at all. Okay, cool.
No, it's very unstable. like this still
does not really work at all yet.
So, we have to have like this. And
let's just make sure we have this.
Not that at all.
Let's go see what this crazy um code
book thing is.
We can actually have the KL and all this
Where was the uh
this one?
Okay. So, where's the uh
the sampling thing for this
logic shaped
size?
Okay.
So, there needs to be a way of
Okay. So, there needs to be a way of sampling
I don't understand the uh the sampling
bit here
how they do Yes.
thing is only 200 lines.
They giving me so much trouble.
trying to find the dang uh the
representation that they've got.
Vector of multiple categoricals.
The learned prior is used for
imagination.
Is there not um
there's a trick I can use for this,
isn't there?
N categoricals.
Oh, wait. Yeah, this is going to this
messes up your
Is there some like weird differentiation
he's doing here?
Image predictor outputs the mean
diagonal Gaussian likelihood.
Okay. So, there is this categorical
latence thing that I don't understand
how we
how we do.
Okay. Well, I don't know how to
implement this fast, but I think I see
what they're doing at the very least.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Wait. I can do this. I
can totally do.
which is this is
this operates on
and then was it encode
dynamics I believe.
So, not not quite what we're going for
here, right?
Oh, no. Hang on.
Um,
What now?
Oh, probably this exact same bloody
thing, right?
Well, I suppose we can do um
the simple version.
This
build data.
Okay. This is this architecture. This
still learns, right?
So with the sampling in place, this
still learns
something at least,
So, we're going to have to go through
look for more model details, look for
other things.
Oh, well, hang on. We actually
we can implement the KL losses now,
right?
Yeah, we'll be able to implement KL
losses. So, we'll actually get a lot
closer to the original. Hang on. Here's
a restroom real quick
AC and I'll be back in a minute.
Is not easy,
you know.
I do wonder though if at least with um
when I get this kale lost in place if
it'll make a difference.
See
where is it?
paper.
What is it? It's
It's a KL on Z.
E and Q, right? So,
yeah. So, it's just
you sample both and then it's just the
difference
it's going to be
the representation loss is stop grad on
what's
dynamics
Whoop!
Okay.
Yeah, you can't give it uh give it
zeros. Fine.
Okay, good. Now we actually do have the
distributions.
Oh, right. because it's it's just the
categorical, right?
we should ask what the hell's wrong with
these?
They shouldn't be all zeros.
All right. So, where did uh where did
this grow up? Huh?
I just like give it zero logit or
something
encountering pro. Oh, it has to be
a soft max.
Ah lo all ns lovely
logits or nans
why my logits ns
Uh okay. So it is it's these losses
producing lovely nans.
some reason.
Okay.
Um,
Well, I'm sure that that has to be
summed differently, right?
Oh, and those aren't mean squared errors
either.
Uh, why is this thing nan out like
instantly though?
Yeah. Input and target. So probably it
wants
all Z hat,
all Z detach.
Ah, yes, this does do it. Well, does it
actually or did I comment it? Oh, this
does do it. Okay, so I just had the uh
the law screwed up.
Holy
slow.
My god,
that is disgustingly slow.
I mean what else do we do with this
though? Like it's kind of just what it
is. No,
I mean we can reduce the um
code book size I suppose.
I was updating all the tensors, not just
new. I told you it's got to be faster
than that, right?
we not try like maybe we try just like
simple VAE type thing
assuming this isn't going to actually do
anything.
I mean, this is like too slow to be
usable, right?
I was like looking at it when I was
implementing it like I there's no way
this is fast, right?
We'll let it run a little bit just in
case to see if it does anything, but I
don't think it even does.
Thanks. Lower normal STM.
Very fun.
Yeah. Welcome to researchers like not
giving two shits about making things in
a way that's at all efficient and like
pretending that they're making progress
on stuff.
Like I mean what is this right?
we can use at least do Gaussian, right?
And then like for comparison
Do you just take this and then use it as
the mean or do you transform it?
This one I'm confident like a stupid LM
won't mess up, right?
transform first.
Oh, wait. Does this actually doing
something?
damn it? Of course, it starts actually
doing something.
So slow.
All right. Maybe we'll leave this alone
for a second.
Yeah. And this is the full version as
well.
Okay. So, this is actually doing
something, guys.
This is actually a version of the world
model
uh running here.
But this actually is a working world
model based.
Yeah, this is a working Let me commit
this right now before I break anything.
See, I was almost not going to even run
the experiment, though, because I mean,
that's like a ludicrous
Oops. That's like a a ludicrous amount
of time
Look up.
They have an ablation on this though.
Oh, wait. This is Dreamer V2, isn't it?
This is V3.
This is a crazy number. The thing like
it's 100 million frames but on one GPU
for 9 days.
That's like an obscene to give you an
idea, right? We go through a 100 million
frames in like 30 seconds.
Where is this damn thing? the or am I
thinking of the other paper.
Where's the um
Where's the the blation?
Hell do you even need to sample this
thing at all?
I mean now I can ask some other
questions at the very least, right?
So first of all, let's just train this
thing again. See if it works
consistently
and then we'll try the larger network.
We'll try a lot of stuff.
There's a lot of stuff. It could be a
lot of stuff. It
no sample.
And apparently this is supposed to
eventually
learn something, right?
Yeah, there it is.
Kind of
to do that. Um, oh, you know what? Good
call. Thank you very much for that.
You've saved me a lot of time.
I didn't realize it left the debug
setting on.
There we go.
of course the question is going to be
did we just get lucky or what's going on
here right
we definitely saw it go to 60 before
this very unstable
The fact that it like jumps up above
random every so often.
Yeah. I like it leads me to believe it's
just super unstable.
not as consistent. No,
it wasn't ever consistent.
Okay, let's figure out the next thing.
Lucky with You can get lucky. Yes. But
the thing is for you to even get lucky
like the algorithm has to at least be
doing something.
You can't just like randomly like
optimize random You can't just optimize
random gradients, right? You have to
actually have something in there.
Yeah, like that. I It's just very
unstable. I think.
The representation loss is supposed to
be
It's so sad cuz like the way this paper
is written, it's it really seems like
the gold standard for science and it
just isn't.
It's like so close, but unfortunately
not.
Your loss scale is one. But the gloss
scale is one. Yeah. Yeah. So this is
actually fine.
The replay ratio here is
steps.
there any reason that we would
this
overexlaining
look I mean the thing is in this case
it's just like it looks like a very like
rigorous paper but at least from all the
followup we did it really just isn't
Well, there are several things we can
actually potentially see here,
All right.
It's technically possible um the
terminals could mess up carpole
specifically.
We can let this run a little bit at
least.
Wait, how the heck does this all
terminals?
Oh, it's cuz I sample it. It's fine.
Now, it bothers me as well that even
when you give it
you give it ground truth, that's still
not enough to make it fully solve.
Right? Like if I do this,
say, "Hey, we're going to give you
ground truth obs
and
action.
Oh no, then it's screwed.
Okay, so maybe I understood, right?
but wait, really?
Well, that ought to work.
Oh, it's the fact that Yeah. Yeah. Hang
on.
Hang on.
So the values need to be
range terminals
for that.
You're going through this weird sample
base net as well that needs to be
learned.
That does make it kind of tricky,
doesn't it?
Like isolate.
Best thing I can kind of do is just let
it cheat with uh using the real data.
So arguably this should technically be
worse.
It does work. I mean, it does at least
learn somewhat though under this
setting.
You think it's a bug or do I think it's
just instability in general is the
question.
Yeah, it's just it's very unstable. I
believe
I'm looking for like errors like if I
have an off by one in the losses or
something
cuz that was sure wouldn't help.
How do they have this is negative log?
It's a weird loss.
This kale balance.
Oh,
I I think
do we think that there's like a
fundamental difference architecture
scale?
I don't think so.
I should probably figure out what he
means by these losses.
Wait, what the heck are these log losses
then?
What are these log losses that he has
here?
Okay, there's something very weird then
with the way that they're doing this.
Okay. Okay. I'm not understanding then
how
so this is a latent
Ah.
Uh.
I don't understand how these um these
distributions are being applied such
that they're getting uh the output of
the entire net as a distribution. Here's
a restroom real quick. I'll be right
back.
Oh, I clearly um missed something about
the way
that this is being constructed
because there's uh
they're getting like a distribution all
the way through the net somehow if I can
understand this.
So they have a distribution
MSC
What in the
So MSC?
latent is a distribution
and then you call the continuous head on
the latent,
right?
Okay. So, observe
and then you do get latent.
Okay.
Get the deterministic and stochastic
representation.
Uh, okay.
That to me just looks like a vector. No.
Is it just a vector?
So, how the hell are we uh
how the hell are we sampling this thing?
No, this is this gives you a
distribution.
Do log prob.
Okay. So
do MLP
edges flex
have blah blah blah.
Okay. So you get
you call get dist on x. Okay, so you
actually you're just doing a normal ass
thing, right? And then you do get
distribution of x.
Oh, okay.
So,
and does this thing have a distribution
to it? This type is Berni by default,
Oh, wait. So, Berni, this is the same as
doing cross entropy for this one, right?
But then, wait, what about observations?
decoder
of latent and decoder gets log probed
with ops.
Okay.
Uh, and this does not have any keywords
on it.
So, what the hell?
So random how this returns to the basic
mark of a whole.
It doesn't return to that. It's these
are just being used as like action
distributions. It's not
not a Berni process.
All the papers are about Gaussian deep
learning.
I think that the best thing you can do
to like have some clarity on this, if
you just check my guide, like the vast
vast majority of this is just like
noise,
right? Like the fact that there's all
this stuff in here, I guarantee you that
it can be like a third of this amount of
stuff in here.
Part of this is Jack's being terrible.
Part of this is like this paper being
overly con convoluted. Um,
there's just like a der of references on
this.
Okay, so this has MSSE.
Wait, what?
What?
Is there any bloody difference then?
Wait, how the
That's so screwy.
Oh, it is.
Wait, but do you actually you don't
sample, do you?
I'm pretty sure this is just moronic.
One second.
One of us is a Okay, so this is
mode
obsis.m mode.
identity
help.lo. So this just gives you the
means,
right? This literally gives you the
means.
Okay. So then this does
This is the dumbest I've ever seen.
Do you see this? Okay. Instead of just
writing mean squared error, they come up
with a mean squared error distribution,
define 10 functions on it and then they
define log prob of a mean squared error
to be equal to the negative mean squared
error. They return
log prob and then they do
Yeah. Then they do negative of that
negative squared error so that they can
have something that resembles a negative
log prop even though it's completely
not.
Get out of here. Actually, just get out
of here. Stupid mathematicians making
complicated for no reason.
Literally would have been a oneline mean
squared error.
You needed one line, you wrote 100.
Therefore, you're 100x stupid. Jeez,
that pisses me off.
Yeah. No, you could do it in one line.
It's literally a standard mean squared
error obfiscated with four layers of
Okay. Well, then we can assume from
there
This is just going to be mean squared
error as well. This is going to be mean
squared error.
We're very we're just we're fine here.
Now the only thing we need to figure out
is the KL div.
I think this is the batch man.
Duction should be batch man for
This is fine. 16
by 16, right?
if they have any more details about
this.
Okay. So, here is
some information
batch size.
But what is this batch length of 64?
Yeah.
That is interesting.
Oh wait, was it
critic lost both to imagine trajectories
I need to find the um the batches
batch sizes for this stuff.
Okay. So you sample from the buffer
and you do agent
Okay, this has to have a train, right?
Act.
Okay. So it does
train model
imagine train policy
weird.
We have train model imagine.
not making a good argument for Jack's
not being a complete garbage uh
framework here.
This code is
uh Imagine.
Okay. So I guess the the question is
like how many of these do we have and
how many of the others do we have?
Model opt.
Awesome.
Config in here.
Of course not. Why the hell would there
be a config?
okay so we have we do have different
learning rates
for these two 3 E - 5 1 E minus
this anywhere in the paper
Yeah. So, neither of those are there.
Cool.
Okay. So, they don't actually pass
anything, guys.
So, how does it know how um how much to
roll out?
you can't find this type of stuff in
There.
I mean, at the very least,
there's no loop here, right? So, Oh,
wait. It's Jack. There wouldn't be a
loop. Damn it.
massively higher learning rate for the
model.
Three. No, it's not massively. It's like
3x higher. Okay.
And the policy So,
I actually have pretty much the whole
thing implemented at this point, I
believe, minus the dumb tricks.
go do this then it just doesn't learn
anything.
So then I guess do we just set up a
sweep on this? Is that all we can do?
I don't think we have everything fully
there yet, but
We use
Do we even use these?
Oh, wait. We're not really training uh
a value function now, are we?
Okay, then that's totally wrong, right?
Well, no, actually, cuz it's
being trained separately. Okay, that's
fine.
I mean most of these just do not matter
right
tune the optimizer
right. So, we're just going to see if we
can set up like
some basic thing. If there are any
stable hypers in here, then I won't have
to worry about it at least.
Of
course.
Go check one thing.
Uh yeah, our value comes from the
policy.
Wait, what the heck is the value trained
against?
Oh,
we're doing J E.
Hallucinated values and rewards.
That one's a bit iffy, right?
we go hunting for
other issues.
Hm.
Interesting that it does so badly on uh
breakout.
Wait, what is this? Atari learning
curves.
And we we actually have breakout solved
in that at least our version.
Batch size is 16 sequences of length 64.
16 sequences of length 64.
Did you go to Rich Sutton Talk? Yeah, I
did.
architecture.
I mean, it's not like
it's not concrete enough to say anything
about, right? It's like a totally up in
the air thing.
cognitive architectures. Well, if you
have an if you actually have like Oops.
If you actually have like a thing that
you've built and run experiments on,
that's one thing. If you're kind of just
saying, "What if we did something like
this?" That's very different.
And
I think continuous learning continual
learning is very important. Um yeah, but
I don't I don't see any way to do it
fundamentally
like how
I don't think you're going to get like
an algorithmic guarantee on continual
learning of any variety.
I'd be very surprised.
I don't know. I haven't even seen any
like apparently there's a thing for like
linear the linear case or whatever that
I haven't seen.
H. Well, that's not
Well,
This supposed to be from the Oh, I see
why this is okay.
But this is the previous state. What the
hell?
Yeah.
Wait, so you encode?
Yeah. No, this doesn't make sense.
Okay. a Twitter stream so much better
than YouTube. Really?
Usually people tell me that the uh the
twi the uh the Twitter stream has the
most delay of any of them.
I'm on uh XY YouTube and Twitch all the
time.
Let me go look at this architecture
again.
Doesn't this seem screwy that it's this
full sample base thing?
I got to go in a few as well. They have
a meeting.
I've made some progress on this today. I
suppose it's just going to take a while.
YouTube is one minute delay. Twitter is
20 seconds. Oh, it shouldn't be a minute
delay. It should be less. Twitch is
usually the best for latency. YouTube
has all my VODs and other videos and
then Twitter X whatever has uh articles
and posts and things.
So wait, so you get this is a
distribution, right? you sample.
Are these all supposed to be independent
samples?
like you pass an H, but this is the
previous step. So the only way that you
see OBS
is through the latent, I guess.
I can at least go log the the different
losses I suppose.
I suppose the thing I'm I'm missing
still is
maybe it's in this on.
I see.
Okay, so I missed the KL balancing step
thing.
Okay, so that's one thing to mess with
else.
Okay. So according to this this is very
important.
Where did they not just have this in
here?
Oh, okay. So, it's different. And I
actually have this already.
As long as I've done these the correct
way,
I believe I have.
Because this is stop grad on
the Z hat, right?
All right. Yeah, that's my uh my signal
to
that is my uh my signal to get going.
All
right, I will keep looking at this stuff
though. Uh, so for the folks who have
been watching the research streams over
the last few days, thank you for tuning
in. This is uh kind of just tough in the
weeds work. But the upside of this if I
make this work is very very big. So, it
would essentially fix the remaining
holes in Puffer Lib and I don't know,
solve all the things.
And in any event,
if you're interested in my work, go
check out the GitHub. It's all open
source. Star the repo. It's free. Helps
me out a ton. Join the Discord if you
want to get involved.
And uh Oh, yeah. Mamba would be awesome.
Uh join Discord if you want to get
involved. And otherwise, you can follow
me on X for more RL content. Thank you.
And I will see you tomorrow. Most likely
tomorrow.